(upbeat music)
Did you guys hear the news?
What?
It's Drew's birthday.
Oh my God!
Happy birthday, Drew!
Happy birthday, Drew.
We love you.
♪ Happy birthday to Drew ♪
♪ Happy birthday dear Drew, happy birthday to Drew ♪
♪ And many more ♪
Are you one, are you two,
are you three, are you four, are you five, are you six.
Sorry we have to add another hour to this show.
Yeah.
Hi, Drew, it's Gordan your favorite chef,
wishing you a very happy birthday from Gordan and Oscar.
Lots of love.
Holy moly oly, it's your birthday!
Happy birthday, Drew.
Peach and I love you so much, we're your biggest fans
and we just want to say happy birthday Drew you.
Isn't that right?
You you've been a huge inspiration
and just a light in my life
and I'm so happy to see you thriving and killing it.
and talking to all my friends on your show.
Sing to her peach, sing to her.
♪ Happy birthday Drew you ♪
(upbeat music)